اتصل المدرس عبر الاتصال الداخلي قائلاً إن
هذا ليس تدريبًا ، يذهب الجميع في
الزاوية
ويكونوا هادئين حقًا وما زلت
أرني الآن كيف تستخدم حقيبة الظهر المضادة للرصاص ،
لا يمكنني التنفس ، حسنًا ،
عمل جيد إذا قال المعلم الغرب ثم أنت
لست بحاجة إلى حقيبة ظهرك ، دعنا ندخل
في الزاوية ،
وأقول لا ، أنا بحاجة إليها ، إنها ممتلئة
[موسيقى] ،
يعتقد كل والد جيدًا أن هذا لن
يحدث لنا
إلا بعد إجراء تدريبات
في المدرسة لمتسلل كل بضعة
أشهر.  فقط في حالة ما إذا كنت قد انتهيت
للتو مما فعلوه في المدرسة ، لقد
أضفت للتو حقيبة ظهر مضادة للرصاص
[موسيقى]
كان لديه أسئلة حول الرجل السيئ الذي
تعرفه وأراد معرفة ما إذا كان يمكن أن
يحدث ذلك في مدرسته
ومن ثم حاولت  أجب على
أسئلته بشكل مناسب للعمر
ثم شرحت له عن
حقيبة الظهر المضادة للرصاص وهو يعلم
أن هذا هو نوع الأشياء مثل
استخدام ضباط الشرطة
[الموسيقى]
حسنًا ، أعتقد أن الشيء الجيد هو أنها
لم تحاول إخافته و  أقول أن
هذا سيحدث ق  من الواضح أنه كان
يمنحه بعض المهارات ويجعله يمارس
ما يقلقني بالإضافة إلى حقيقة
أنك تعلم أننا لا نعرف أن
حقائب الظهر المضادة للرصاص تعمل وأنا
أكره أن يعتقد الآباء أنه يتعين عليهم الخروج
وشراء هذه
الأشياء الباهظة الثمن  يتم تسويقها عندما يكونون
قد يفعلون أو لا يفعلون أي شيء جيد تعرفه في
الإغلاق ، فسيقوم المدرسون
تلقائيًا بإغلاق الباب ومن ثم
جعل جميع الطلاب يبتعدون عن الأنظار ، لذلك إذا كان
هناك طفل يركض
لحقيبة الظهر ، فأنا لا أفعل ذلك  هو أن الطفل الذي
يركض أمام النافذة هو ذلك
الطفل الذي يركض في مكان قد
لا يكون محميًا ومن ثم مثل
الأطفال الآخرين سيبدأون في فعل ذلك
أيضًا ، لا ألوم الوالدين ، أعتقد أنه إذا
كنت تعرف الوالدين  من
الصواب أن تخاف ،
لكن ما نفعله حيال ذلك أو إلى أين نذهب
من هنا يحتاج إلى النظر بعناية شديدة في
المكاتب
التي هي حقائب ظهر مضادة للرصاص وهي عبارة عن كاميرات أمنية مضادة للرصاص
من طراز ar-15s الموجودة في المدارس
هي إمكانات طويلة الأجل أه  يسبب ضررًا
نفسيًا
واجتماعيًا
للأطفال في تلك المدارس ، مع وجود
أطفال صغار جدًا
يتجولون معتقدين أنه قد يتم
إطلاق النار عليهم
في أي لحظة
ويمكن أن يخلق الكثير من القلق والكثير
من
الاكتئاب والكثير من الخوف الذي لا
داعي له وربما لا  له ما يبرره لأن هناك
طرقًا أخرى للعيش في أمان ، لم يكن
خائفًا من القيام بالتمرين ، ولا يخاف
من الذهاب إلى المدرسة أو أي شيء من هذا القبيل ،
لكن
كونه خمسة أعوام ، كلهم ​​يدورون حول
الأشرار والأبطال الخارقين والأشياء التي
كان علي أن أشرحها لك  حسنًا ، إنه
أخطر قليلاً من ذلك ، فأنا
أقف بجانب ما كان في الفيديو كما
قلت لم يكن مثل التدريبات الخاصة بنا التي صنعناها ،
لقد كان ما يفعله في المدرسة
فقط مع إضافة حقيبة الظهر المضادة للرصاص
وأتمنى أن نتمكن من ذلك  افعل شيئًا
مختلفًا ، لكنني أشعر أنه
يمنح الكثير من الآباء راحة البال الإضافية
مع العلم أنه
إذا لم يكونوا بحاجة إليه على الأقل ،
فسيحصلون عليه بدلاً من الحاجة إليه ولا يجب
أن يكون الوالدان مناسبين للعمر  إجراء
محادثات مع أطفالهم حول
المواقف المخيفة ،
وأعتقد أن الرسالة الرئيسية للأطفال الأصغر سنًا هي
أننا نبذل قصارى جهدنا للاعتناء
بك